you're staring observation must be one
of your superhuman abilities I've had
masked visitors before but they came
either to kill me or have sex with me on
one memorable occasion both but you are
my first superhero did you make quite an
entrance the roof
I assume you wanted to establish your
hero credentials and then wait to your
words you know what people say an
earring in your doorbell an association
between us could place you in danger
your enemy is our Legion I take it you
know you're gonna have to take that off
to drink that right it is imperative for
my safety and that of my loved ones why
should I have a confused need with
fetish you got onto our roof either fire
escape next door your particular
musculature and ability to make that
entrance indicate expertise in
freerunning but a slight hunch speaks to
a job which involves frequent bending
from the waist you smell of organic
compounds rather than to printing
solvents you work in a print shop
probably in a story where according to
the Internet the standard bearer walks a
beat
long story short your secret identity is
here purely notional so take off the
mask please
how'd you do all that I was bitten by
radioactive detective how did you get my
number and address